hi thanks for stopping by my name is
Michael Kim and in this video I'm going
to tell you about our paper at itcs2023
on loss minimization through the lens of
outcome indistinguishability
this is Joint work with parikshit
gopalan lunja who Omer reingold and Udi
veeder
this talk will consist of roughly three
parts
in the first part I'll tell you about a
recent work which actually appeared at
the last itcs that revisits the idea of
lost minimization through a solution
concept called omnipredictors
in the second part I'll tell you about a
different but related line of work that
proposes an alternative Paradigm for
learning than lossment musician called
outcome in distinguishability
and then finally with these Notions in
place I can tell you about our results
from this paper that derive new
omnipredictor guarantees via outcome in
distinguishability
so with that let's begin discussing loss
minimization and Omni prediction
so loss minimization is the central
problem of supervised learning theory in
this problem first we fix a loss
function L some measure of the quality
of a prediction for a given outcome then
we're given a hypothesis class H and
we're told to find the hypothesis that
minimizes the expected loss over the
class h
okay so here I'm using F sub L
intentionally as our hypothesis to
emphasize the fact that the optimal
choice of hypothesis may depend
intimately on the choice of loss
function
in particular conventional wisdom tells
us that if we fix a new loss function
then we'll need to re-run loss
minimization to find the optimal
hypothesis
recent work however has questioned this
wisdom is the choice of loss function
actually essential or is it possible to
learn a single predictor that minimizes
many losses simultaneously that is a
single hypothesis F that competes with
the best loss specific hypothesis over
many different choices of loss l
pretty quickly we can see that this
formulation of loss Independent Learning
doesn't quite make sense though uh
natural loss natural choices of losses
will require different optimal
predictions
right so for instance if our task is to
Simply predict a Bernoulli random
variable with bias two-thirds then under
the squared loss the optimal prediction
will be the mean of two-thirds but under
the L1 loss the optimal prediction is
the median of one
so if we want any hope of this lost
Independent Learning we need some way of
resolving these apparent conflicts
between different losses
the key Insight of omni predictors is to
allow for post-processing of the
predictions
in this recent work gopalan kalai
reingold Sharon and veter proposed the
notion of an omni predictor
parameterized by a collection of losses
an omnipredictor is a single predictor
that achieves the loss minimization
guarantee for every loss in the
collection after applying a simple
post-processing on the prediction
so what is this post-processing function
we post-process the predictions as if
they tell us the probability of the
outcome why
formally we can Define the
post-processing Tau sub L as an
argumentimization over the predictions
but importantly it's a simple univariate
optimization that is completely
determined by the loss L and independent
of our chosen predictor and if we pass
in the true probability governing the
outcome y then we obtain the optimal
prediction under the given loss l
so returning to earlier examples for the
squared loss or really any so-called
proper loss the optimal post-processing
is simply the identity function
whereas for L1 the post-processing will
round to the closest binary value
with this post-processing in place we
can understand the definition of
omnipredictors
for a loss class l a hypothesis class H
and some error parameter Epsilon an LH
Epsilon omnipredictor gives us an
efficient way to make Epsilon optimal
predictions compared with hypotheses in
h under any loss in the class l
so at this point I encourage you to
pause the video and stare at the
definition for a moment because this
will be the central notion of the
remainder of the talk
as with any new definition though we
need to ask ourselves whether the notion
of omni predictors is actually feasible
so the first thing to note is that the
Bayes optimal predictor is actually an
omni predictor
I'll use this notation P star of x to
denote the optimal predictor that gives
the true probability of the outcome
being one given X in other words we can
think of our outcomes as being drawn as
Bernoulli's with parameters P star of x
okay so with that it's not hard to see
that the that P star this base optimal
predictor actually gives us an omni
predictor this follows essentially from
the definition of the optimal
post-processing function Tau Sabel
um but while the base optimal predictor
tells us that in principle
omnipredictors exist its complexity may
be totally unreasonable we really don't
have any bounds on that so uh instead we
may ask for a practical feasibility
result do efficient omnipredictors exist
for instance with complexity scaling in
terms of the complexity of our chosen
hypothesis class h
and the main result of the Omni
predictors paper is to show such a
feasibility result in particular they
showed that efficient omnipredictors
exist for the class of all convex loss
functions in complexity that is
completely independent of P star
so that is for any prediction task
there's a single predictor P tilde that
I can learn of complexity roughly that
of the hypotheses in h such that for any
convex loss that you then pick
post-processing my predictor P tilde
gives the optimal predictions under your
loss
the proof of this theorem actually goes
by demonstrating a connection to work on
a notion of algorithmic fairness called
multi-calibration
the result says roughly that in each
multi-calibrated predictor is actually a
convex Omni predictor for the hypothesis
class h
so this connection reveals a very nice
result on how to efficiently construct
Omni predictors but leaves a few
outstanding questions
first of all what about other classes of
loss functions the original work
Leverage is a delicate argument tailored
to convex losses and multi-calibration
but what if we want a different class of
losses
also we may wonder if multi-calibration
is really necessary
multi-calibration gives us
omnipredictors whose complexity scales
linearly in the complexity of H but with
a large polynomial factor in the error
parameter Epsilon and it's it's
reasonable to wonder whether some weaker
but more efficient alternatives to
multi-calibration like multi-accuracy or
low degree multi-calibration actually
suffice for Omni prediction as well
so in this work we address these
questions giving a simple recipe to
construct Omni predictors for any lost
class under considerably weaker
requirements than full multi-calibration
in all our work demonstrates that rather
than being this delicate and rare notion
Omni prediction is actually a broad and
very general phenomenon and it can be
achieved in many interesting cases in
complexity comparable to traditional
loss minimization
now that we have established the
definition and prior results on Omni
predictors we'll switch gears for the
moment to introduce the idea of outcome
in distinguishability
keep in mind that our goal is to find a
direct construction of omni predictors
we'll adopt the approach of outcome in
distinguishability intuitively outcome
in distinguishability or oi requires
that predictions should look like the
Bayes optimal probabilities
my co-authors dork reingold rothblum
Jonah and I introduced oi in the context
of algorithmic fairness originally as a
generalization of multi-calibration
since then oi has taken on a life of its
own and as we'll see offers an
alternative to loss minimization as a
principled paradigm for learning
to motivate the formal definition of OI
consider the following cartoon setup
I'll present to you a triple of an input
x a prediction P tilde of X and an
outcome Y and additionally a promise to
you that this outcome Y is sampled
according to one of two worlds
in the first world Y is sampled from the
real distribution it's a true outcome
which we'll refer to as nature okay and
denote by y star being sampled according
to the Bayes optimal probability P star
of x
in the other world Y is sampled
according to our predictive model okay
and we'll denote this by y tilde being
sampled according to the probability P
tilde of X that I've revealed to you
okay so it's a Bernoulli flip according
to the probability that is presented in
the triple
and your job then is to distinguish
which of these two cases it came from
okay to guess whether why the outcome
that you're observing is drawn according
to Nature or according to the
probability that I've presented to you
so at least at an intuitive level we say
that a predictor P tilde is outcome
indistinguishable if you cannot tell
whether the outcome was sampled
according to Nature or to the from the
predictor
of course uh for this notion to make
sense we need to discuss precisely what
indistinguishability really means so
here we'll appeal to computational
indistinguishability
parameterizing our notion by uh
distinguisher algorithms that take in an
input X the prediction P tilde of X and
an outcome Y and the the job of the
algorithm the distinguishers is to guess
whether the outcome came from nature or
from P tilde
more formally we parameterize a li by a
collection of distinguishers
given a distinguisher Class A and an
error parameter of Epsilon a predictor P
tilde is a Epsilon o i if for every
algorithm in the class the probability
that the algorithm accepts on outcomes
drawn from nature
is Epsilon close to the acceptance
probability on outcomes drawn according
to the predictor
as with Omni predictors we need to ask
whether oi is feasible and again we can
see that oi is feasible because the
optimal predictor satisfies the notion
in particular the optimal predictor is
indistinguishable from itself but for
the same reasons as before this is not a
very interesting feasibility result so
the important question to ask is whether
efficient oi predictors exist with
complexity scaling now in terms of the
complexity of the distinguishers
again the answer is yes
we show that efficient oi predictors can
be learned with complexity scaling in
terms of the distinguisher complexity
and independent of Nature's complexity
now that we have both pieces Omni
predictors and outcome in
distinguishability we can turn our
attention finally to learning
omnipredictors via outcoming
distinguishability
so the first key idea of our work is to
design a distinguisher class based off
of a loss class and a hypothesis class
so consider building up the following
class where for each loss L and
hypothesis H are distinguisher a sub l h
computes the difference between the loss
achieved by the optimal post-processing
of the probability P tilde of X and the
hypothesis h of X in predicting the
outcome y right
so note that by construction this
distinguisher returns a negative value
if and only if the loss of the
prediction P to live X is smaller than
that of H of x
okay so that will be important
and once we have this class of
distinguishers then we can just turn the
crank and ask for outcome in
distinguishability so in this new
variant of OI which we call loss oi we
require that the difference in the loss
under the true outcomes is similar to
the difference in the loss under
outcomes generated according to P tilde
of x
Okay so
the definition what good is it well it
turns out it's really good our main
result shows that loss oi suffices for
Omni prediction
that is if a predictor is L each Epsilon
loss outcome indistinguishable then it
is an LH Epsilon omnipredictor
okay
so uh once we have the right components
the proof really almost writes itself
and only requires three lines
um so let's go through it the proof
follows a a simple indistinguishability
argument first we observe that by
definition of Tau sub L the optimal
post-processing of P tildevx actually
achieves optimal loss on outcomes y
tilde drawn according to P tilde of x
I know that was a mouthful but the point
is that that if we can switch to a world
where the outcomes are drawn according
to P tilde of X then we know that P
tilde of X gives us the optimal
decisions the optimal predictions
okay so then by indistinguishability the
loss on Nature's outcomes y star must be
similar to the loss of on the modeled
outcomes so P tilde must therefore also
achieve near optimal loss on the real
outcomes
okay so that's the intuition let's go
through it
formally our goal will be to compare the
two expected losses here for each l and
H
okay so we can start by subtracting them
which allows us to rewrite this
difference in terms of the expectation
of this distinguisher that we defined a
sub l h
by Los Hawaii then we can switch from an
expectation over Nature's outcomes to
one over the modeled outcomes right so
we're switching from y star to Y tilde
by this loss oi condition
okay and then expanding out the
difference in losses we know that this
difference is at most Zero by the
optimality of the post-processing of P
tilde of X on outcomes drawn according
to P tilde effects that's basically it
rearranging the inequality we can see
that the loss of our predictor is at
most that of h plus Epsilon
so in particular it's Epsilon optimal
over the hypothesis class h
in other words P tilde must be an omni
predictor
so far we've seen a new recipe for
obtaining Omni predictors for any loss
class
but this construction leverages oi while
oi is feasible generically it's no more
efficient than multi-calibration so it's
not immediately clear that we've made
any progress on the efficiency front
to understand how efficiently we can
achieve loss oi will actually decompose
this condition into two simpler
conditions
we call the first condition decision oi
which captures indistinguishability of
the first loss of the predictor's
decisions
and the second condition hypothesis oi
which captures indistinguishability of
the loss achieved by each hypothesis in
our class
each condition turns out to be
relatively simple to enforce
first decision oi is closely related to
the notion of calibration importantly
here though we mean overall calibration
not multi-calibration okay so overall
calibration is a simple condition to
enforce with sample and time efficient
algorithms
for the second condition we show that
hypothesis oi is actually equivalent to
multi-accuracy for a class of loss
functions which we denote C sub l h
that can be derived from the discrete
derivatives of losses evaluated on each
hypothesis from the class h
um I don't have time to talk about
exactly what this class is but uh and
the point is we have to be careful about
how we reason about this derived class
but all that said multi-accuracy is a
much simpler condition than
multi-calibration again in terms of
sample and computational complexity
the upshot putting everything together
is that we derive a new set of
sufficient conditions for Omni
prediction in particular if a predictor
is calibrated and multi-accurate over
this derived Class C sub LH then it is
an LH omnipredictor in other words
multi-accuracy plus calibration suffices
for Omni prediction without
multi-calibration
we instantiate this General recipe
to derive Omni predictors for concrete
loss classes and we'll talk about that
next
towards our initial goal this recipe
allows us to talk about non-convex loss
classes
without going too far into the details
we show a sufficient condition to be an
omni predictor for all loss functions of
course this means that our derived class
see all H has to reason Beyond H itself
okay to include the set of all functions
that we may compose with h and with
hypotheses from H but still it's an
explicit description of a class of
functions for which calibration and
multi-accuracy suffice to give Omni
prediction
restricting ourselves a bit further we
can look at the set of all Lipschitz
losses still known convex but we get an
even simpler class of functions that
requires us to reason about threshold
functions over our hypotheses in a sense
we can view these results in two ways on
the one hand it shows a feasibility
result for Lipschitz Omni predictors we
only have to learn uh you know a
threshold multi-cal multi-accurate
predictor on the other hand it shows a
barrier to achieving this multi-accuracy
over thresholds of our hypothesis class
as it implies a very strong Omni
predictor guarantee
we can also go in the other direction
considering a restricted class of convex
loss functions that arise from
generalized linear models
for this class of losses we show that no
modification to the hypothesis class is
necessary
in particular for any hypothesis class H
if P tilde is calibrated and H
multi-accurate then P tilde is actually
an omni predictor for the glm losses
over h
this result demonstrates the surprising
power of these weak forms of
multi-calibration demonstrating a strong
guarantee from only multi-accuracy with
overall calibration
so this concludes the overview of our
main conceptual results we have a number
of more technical results in the paper
along with many details that I've
glossed over but I hope you've come away
with an appreciation for the powerful
guarantee of omni prediction and the
versatility of outcome in
distinguishability as a principled
paradigm for learning
to conclude I want to leave you with a
more General perspective on oi we saw
how oi provided a clean recipe for
learning Omni predictors but what else
can we learn using oi intuitively a
certain meta algorithm seems to be
emerging in a number of different Works
to show how to learn predictive models
that satisfy formal properties that go
beyond the standard loss minimization
guarantee
and so the approach goes as follows
once you've identified your favorite
formal property Pi the first step is to
prove that Nature's model satisfies the
property then comes the creativity in
devising a set of efficient
distinguishers that somehow fool this
proof
and then finally we turn the crank turn
the oi crank and we learn a predictor P
tilde that is indistinguishable to this
set of tests to these distinguishers
right and so the upshot is that if the
proof can't distinguish between P tilde
and nature then P tilde must satisfy the
property too by our first bullet point
okay and so really a growing list of
Works seem to be following this General
recipe so I hope that uh at next year's
itcs you can add your work to this list
thanks for your attention and enjoy the
conference